[Music]
this morning a return visit from a
master of meat
pat lefreda last appeared on this
broadcast in
2014. since then he's further expanded
his empire now he's out with a new book
glorious beef a mix of personal stories
recipes in the state of his
ever-changing industry
to sample all of it we visited his
one-of-a-kind brand new building just
outside new york city
how big is this
it's 120 feet deep
30 feet wide
30 feet tall
inside pat lafrida's new 20 million
dollar facility in new jersey
is the fort knox of food
the world's largest dry aging room where
millions of dollars worth of meat
up to 15 000 primal cuts
sit for up to 260 days so it should lose
about 15 to 20 percent of its water
weight in the first 21 days and then it
starts to slow down as they lose weight
they concentrate flavor you'll see that
the protein is starting to bevel in
but the bone won't recede the fat won't
recede why is dry aging so important
dry aging is is an art that
adds so much richness and flavor to beef
but it has to be done correctly you have
a lot of fronts
no one does dry aging like lefrida who
runs a family business that first got
its start a century ago
in his new book glorious beef lefreeda
celebrates his family's legacy but also
gets personal talking about his battle
with stomach cancer in 2003 which he
says led him to stop eating processed
meat
he also talks about his service in the
army it shaped me in a way which no
other experience can i mean to be that
regimented to learn how to live through
and thrive through sleep deprivation
was the first thing i thought
you put you pulled an all-nighter last
night i did
and you do it all the time yes
without sleeping no matter what happens
food must go out
since march 16th of 2020 like all meat
production facilities lefreeda meat
purveyors has been under a presidential
mandate never to close now look at my
staff
they're not under presidential mandate
they could have stayed home but they
didn't i owe a lot of that to the army
team building
leadership
and communication a butcher's knife
always has a curved blade despite the
lack of sleep lefreda was still game to
give us a brief butchering demonstration
making one of his favorites skirt steak
pinwheels
once we got the meat trimmed and
seasoned it was time to tie it up
the reason that we tie meat
is so that the density is as symmetrical
as possible because when it's not it
will not cook evenly
so
i'm going to do a butcher's knot real
slow
and you follow along with me okay okay
all right
see i'm holding it yeah
now i'm taking this end yeah i'm going
right over my thumb okay
under
how the hell do you do that
we're gonna do it again
you know what's funny the slower you do
it the harder it is i feel like i'm
teaching my son how to tie his shoes i
want you to he's yelling at you what do
you hold on to only i'm yelling at you
now you're almost there all you need to
know is that i got there eventually
that's it that's it you got it you gotta
look at that perfect
kind of
you do it you do it i'm gonna do it you
did it you did it
the next step was to split the wheel
right down the middle that looks great
yours is going to look just as good you
want you just put yours
beautiful
split it right out right in half
that's
yeah it is beautiful
lefreda finished up the pinwheels in a
makeshift kitchen on the back of his
truck in the alley behind his building
he says the secret here is to cook from
the top down
not the bottom up
there's the tailgate barbecue and then
there's the back alley barbecue
that's the way we do it
are you ready to taste i am ready
creation i'm ready
our personal creation
butchered
cooked
and eaten
by us cheers great job
oh
nothing better glorious beef however is
more than a collection of recipes and
personal stories what always bothered me
was the misinformation about meat i
wanted to go back to a time where i
remembered beef was glorious and that's
where we get the title of the book
glorious beef lefrieda uses the book to
push back against trends he believes
aren't always smart like exclusively
grass fed beef which he says costs too
much and simply doesn't taste as good
i'm not against grass-fed it's just
you'll never get that same sweetness it
only comes from finishing off on green
it's a part of the ongoing organic
versus all natural debate one highly
regulated the other not
neither animals are raised with growth
hormones or antibiotics organic
is one step further where the lands have
to be certified organic you're not a fan
of organic i'm a fan of
of organic i can't justify the costs
organic is probably about 20 to 30
percent higher in cost than all natural
prices fluctuate labels and production
standards evolve but one thing stays the
same good beef is good beef
and for lefreda
that's been a lifetime labor of love
you haven't met too many wealthy
butchers
it's hard work
and one of the reasons that my dad never
wanted me in this business is because
of he didn't want me to have to work
overnight he didn't want me to have to
work in the cold but
it's in the blood what about your kids
i don't want them to suffer through this
either do they want to
they they talk about it i mean i think
my daughter at 11 is more of a fighter
than my son he's more of a lover at 17.
but she reminds me a lot of of my aunt
who was my dad's partner
and it takes a strong personality to to
make it in this industry do you ever see
yourself not doing this
i've never seen myself not doing this
and courtesy of pat lafrida who dropped
these off this morning after cooking
oh my god
personally for you guys engraved look at
that tomahawk steaks that are each about
two feet long i mean this is we have
people taking pictures
my son is eyeballing this like right now
he's like mom get down to philly with
that well it's free you can throw it
back on the grill when you get home i'm
going to eat something i'm not going to
share any with one sean brandy or jack
grand even i took their last name for
this one i mean it smell i mean it
tastes amazing too but this smells so
good i just love that pat
is constantly reinvesting in the
business yeah
like anybody he makes just throws back
in wow to get better at what he does
anyway i will take a bite thank you pat
for dropping yeah i will take a bite in
a moment i promise